delicious meals a friendly pastor and hi
welcome to Chili's one
eternity later
[Applause]
he's already dead first of all huge
thanks to all of you for helping me
reach 600k subscribers I am one step
closer to my parents loving me in this
episode we'll be taking a deep dive into
episode 8 its connection to the game and
details you missed warning there will be
only some minor spoilers in this video
but before we sink our teeth into it
make sure you give a like And subscribe
it's the only thing keeping me going
through these harsh winter months we
open on the resort town of Silver Lake
and trust me you'll want to visit it's
some of the greatest food I've ever had
by this abandoned post office we can
make up the area code 81303 which is the
code for Durango Colorado a popular Ski
Resort destination just like in the game
we get these gorgeous vistas of pine
trees it's a location that looks
beautiful but is terribly inhospitable
in the winter months and you know when
an episode begins with a Bible quote
from The Book of Revelation it can't be
going anywhere good in fact David here
is reciting verse 21 which a lot of you
might remember from Titanic shut life
away all the tears from their eyes
and there shall be no more death so off
to a great start this particular verse
basically depicts the end of days and
that when the earth is gone there will
be no more death or sorrow because how
can there be death and sorrow when
everyone's already dead or in this case
gone to heaven and boy I've never seen a
more sad looking group of people at a
steakhouse since my vegan girlfriend
didn't let my family order meat it out
back I found this ring David wears
really interesting he doesn't wear one
in the game and seeing how he's this
religious figure it made me think of the
Ring the pope wears on that same exact
finger in fact many of the characters in
David's flock have biblical names Josiah
means god supports and heals Timothy one
who honors God and this one is super
interesting James meaning supplanter as
we'll see throughout the episode James
questions David's leadership what's
really cool here is the actor who plays
James is none other than Troy Baker the
actor who portrayed Joel in the game one
big difference from the game is the
show's emphasis on David and religion in
the game David barely mentions God and
the only thing that really hints at the
Town being religious is that same when
we are in need he shall provide banner I
quite enjoyed this change as it made
David a more rounded character and
contextualized his motivation behind the
veil of Christianity he also fancies
himself a protector like Joel but this
type of protection is predatory more on
that in a bit among the crowd is a young
girl named Hannah a Hebrew name meaning
favor or Grace it's kind of ironic since
Grace surely hasn't befallen her or her
family she's just lost her father Alec
we find out was the man Joel killed at
the end of episode 6 at the University
of Eastern Colorado she's wanting to
know when they can bury his body and
check out this Sly glance David gives
James here I'll probably be posting a
separate video on this but this glance
suggests Alex body was taken back and
put into the very soup his own daughter
will later eat that's why David says
it's too cold out and they can't bury
him just yet there's something else
really metaphoric about this church
service taking taking place at a
steakhouse instead of a house of God
it's a house of Todd a Todd's Steakhouse
that is a place where animals are
butchered and eaten David says even we
humans are animals in a sense you're an
animal well yes we all are that's sort
of the point he too will literally be
butchered and his flesh burned as Todd's
Steakhouse Goes Up in Flames a terribly
ironic end for a man who cooked and ate
his own people James explains the dire
situation they only have about a week or
two of meat left later in the episode we
find out there are only a few members
who know that human pieces have been put
into the food and its heavily implied
James is one of these people so when he
says they have little meat left this
could theoretically include human flesh
with their food dwindling and Joel on
the brink of death Ellie must venture
out in the wild and hunt for food in
episode 6 we saw Joel train her how to
shoot but her skills aren't exactly
top-notch
laughs
unlike the game where she successfully
captures this rabbit Ellie takes Joel's
rifle instead of her bow and arrow in
both versions she injures a deer which
leads her to a confrontation between her
and David Ellie's fascination with guns
has been a recurring Motif throughout
the season a gun gives her power that
thing she'd had to rely on others like
Riley Marlene and Joel 4 for most of her
life and she shows off her skills with
Firearms by removing rounds from the
rifles using only one hand aside from
the change in weapons the game and show
versions are almost identical any sudden
moves I put him right between your eyes
ditto for Buddy Boy any sudden moves and
I put one right between your eyes ditto
for Buddy Boy over there we can trade
you for some of the deer we have what do
you need we have boots medicine weapons
ammo clothes medicine in exchange for
medicine penicillin to combat Joel's
infection to be exact Ellie will give
them half of Bambi but in order to get
it James must make the Four Mile round
trip to town and back leaving David and
Ellie to size each other up and for what
it's worth there's room for you in our
group if you want
you're inviting me to your hunger Club
ah got him David informs her that he's
the leader of a group of men women and
children down by the resort and even
though he's a preacher he says they're
not a cult Ellie can't believe anyone
still believes in God especially after
what happened to the world what kind of
loving God would allow that but to her
surprise David found God after the
Apocalypse in fact prior to the pandemic
he was just a second grade teacher
something which is extra concerning
considering what he'll later try to do
to Ellie David wants her to come with
him and join their group which I can't
help but think is an act of
proselytizing or the act of trying to
convert someone from one religion or
belief to another although never
explicitly stated Ellie seems to be
atheist or agnostic when she's asked
about heaven in the game she says I'd
like to believe it
but you don't
I guess not not mentioned in the game is
David's origin according to the show he
was in the Pittsburgh quarantine Zone
when it fell in 2017. you'll remember
the Pittsburgh segment of the game was
swapped for Kansas City in the show
since 2017 to David and his flock have
traveled further and further west due to
frequent attacks by Raiders we saw a few
of these Raiders attempt to take over
Bill and Frank's compound in episode 3.
If Only They Knew Raiders are weak to
remote control operated flamethrowers
now luck has not been on David and his
crew's side as food dwindles no such
thing as luck I believe everything
happens for a reason no such thing as
luck now you see I believe
and everything happens for a reason and
just like in the game David reveals he
knows Ellie's been lying about being
part of a large group that's because it
was his own men that attacked him at the
University back in episode six that
crazy man
was traveling with a little girl the
game departs drastically from the show
here when the two come under attack from
infected I'm actually a bit disappointed
they didn't try to adapt this moment
because it gives us a really important
beat where David saves Ellie's Life by
shooting an infected with a gun he had
hidden this whole time it basically
shows that David could have killed Ellie
at almost any moment but chose not to do
so now at this point in the game or show
for that matter we don't know David is a
cannibal so it adds to this mystery of
whether or not David and his group are
truly good but more importantly I just
think the show needs more infected I'm
not saying David and Ellie had to go
through a wild Chase through an
abandoned Factory where they fight off
hordes of infected including a bloater
but the show could definitely do with
more reminders of the infected threat
their time together also creates a
bonding moment between Ellie and David
that's Huey make a pretty good team
something that could have helped with
that tension later in the episode when
we're wondering if Ellie would join
David's side alas both versions have
James reappearing holding Elliot
gunpoint but David lets Ellie go with
the medicine even after she rejects
joining him that's because David is
smart he knows Ellie isn't with a huge
group won't survive for long on her own
and by letting her go she'll lead them
right to Joel a man who in the game
killed many of David's men Ellie rushes
back to Joel's side and injects him with
Penicillin like in the game she stays by
his side Josiah here arrives with a
delicious helping of what he claims to
be venison
while Hannah's mother Joyce remarks they
only have five more cans of tomato sauce
left Josiah absolutely has to be in on
the cannibal cooking as it looks like he
was the one to chop these pieces up as
I'll mention in my other video he could
knowingly be giving Joyce chunks of her
own husband to cook just take a look at
how Shifty his eyes are here when he
lies to her about this being venison
something is definitely going on the
people of Silver Lake enjoy their meal
at Todd's Steakhouse and even though
they're all starving notice that they
all wait until Grace to enjoy their meal
meanwhile I'd be there getting pissed
that my food's gone cold and what should
be a joyous occasion is met with little
Fanfare as David and James arrive with
Ellie's deer the people have heard a
rumor that the man who killed Alec and
his father is somewhere out there and
David vows to send a group to track him
and Ellie at dawn there will be justice
but Hannah is like
and I kid you not I audibly gas when
David smacked the [__] out of her no one
gets up to stop him it just goes to show
how much of a spell this guy has over
these people now what David says here is
probably the most interesting line in
the entire episode but the truth is
Hannah you will always have a father
and you will show him respect when he's
speaking you could interpret this line
in one of two ways first that David will
be sort of this surrogate father for
Hannah now that her real father is gone
or two that Father Here refers to God in
Christian theology the word father is
often meant to represent God and if
David is telling her to show respect
when he's speaking it hints that David
actually believes God is speaking
through him I find this a much creepier
interpretation now this freaked me out
this extra here looks a lot like Ashley
Johnson the actress who portrayed Ellie
in the game yeah yeah I know I'm
probably crazy but anyways it's probably
not her considering in the season
preview we know she'll make an
appearance in the finale and they
wouldn't give her a non-speaking extra
role unless it was a fun Easter egg and
she happened to be on set that day
David's prayer refers to the living
bread a reference to the act of
communion in which bread is used to
symbolize the Flesh of Christ ironic
since they are all likely eating human
flesh David's people here eat
voraciously all of them starving I found
it interesting that David here is the
only one who's really taking his time
with the meal he definitely isn't giving
off that starved Vibe James also eats
slowly but that's because he knows
they're eating human flesh just watch
him look over at Hannah Joyce and David
it would be super messed up if he knew
Anna was eating her own father back at
Ellie's Hideout we can see her bathe in
this light from the window the Ellie
bathing light imagery has been a common
Motif throughout this season from when
we first see her in episode 1 and also
waking up in episode 2. it Harkens back
to the Firefly motto when you're lost in
the darkness look for the light Ellie is
the light that hope for Humanity Joel's
wound is healing and Ellie gives him
some medicine she even takes a moment to
feed their horse but a group of startled
Birds alert Ellie to David and his men
now James here questions David's
decision to bring Elian alive after all
she'd just be one more mouth to feed but
things get more heated when James
suggests Ellie dying out here is God's
will David stops in his tracks and
there's this beat of tension in between
the two men no words are said but by
questioning David James is questioning
God's Will and he's quick to back down
when sized Up by David Ellie rushes back
to Joel and gives him his knife the dude
can barely keep his eyes open there's
not much she can do for him other than
try to hide the entrance to the basement
and distract David's men away from the
house even as Ellie shoots at them to
draw them away David yells out that he
wants her alive as will later find out
he has a bigger creepier plans for her
James ends up shooting the horse causing
Ellie to Dismount and almost fall
unconscious in the game this plays out
much differently while she is knocked
off her horse it leads her on a lengthy
escape sequence where we see her sneak
through the Lakeside Resort in its
abandoned chalets until she's eventually
caught by David in the show James is
ready to disobey David's order and kill
Ellie before he comes and intercedes
these guys should be taking out their
Vengeance on the person who actually
killed their man so he orders a few of
them to hunt Joel down while the horse
will be scavenged for additional meals
Josiah here is hot on Joel's tracks but
unbeknownst to him Joel can hear him
creaking upstairs like me trying to get
a late night snack now here's something
I want to pose to you did you think
Joel's recovery was rushed he goes from
barely being able to keep his eyes open
to single-handedly taking down three
armed men let me know in the comments
because I'm really conflicted on this
one anyway Josiah gets an absolutely
brutal death with a knife to the back of
the head
[Music]
Ellie wakes up in a cage that would make
Joe Goldberg jealous even the cage here
looks like it's pulled directly from the
game David has come in the hopes of
swaying Ellie to his side after all if
it weren't for him the others would have
already killed her for those with a Keen
Eye you can make out the knives and
butchering board in the background tools
used for the butchering of human
carcasses the game pulls no punches when
Ellie is initially interrogated by David
in fact he's chopping up a human body
when she wakes up the show holds on the
cannibal reveal a bit longer allowing
David to at least attempt to sway Ellie
to his side he says that Ellie's life
with Joel is coming to an end and he's
offering her a new beginning this ties
into the Bible quote from the beginning
in which God ended humanity and led the
righteous to a new beginning in heaven
so Ellie must face reality if she can't
trust David she will end up alone Joel's
apparently been injected with steroids
because he's managed to tie up two of
David's men Marco and Timothy in an
attempt to interrogate them as to
Ellie's whereabouts this scene plays out
almost identical to the game right down
to the very stab to the knee similar to
what he had Marlon and Florence do in
episode 6 Joel makes the men point on
the map where Ellie had been taken to
make sure they aren't lying to him turns
out she's at a place called Silver Lake
not the name of a town but of a resort
and it's kind of ironic that these guys
have undertaken eating humans as a last
resort at a resort there is one line of
dialogue here that isn't in the show
which acknowledges the men no David is
interested in Ellie she's alive this is
Dave it's the most pet I can see why
they cut this from the show as it
implies David had multiple young girls
he had his pets in the past but the
thing I take away most from this scene
is just how violent Joel is especially
when it comes to protecting those he
loves he doesn't have to kill these guys
but does so anyway he's not taking any
chances in this unforgiving world
meanwhile Ellie's wasting no time
looking for a way to escape and as she
tries loosening the bolts to her cage
makes a chilling Discovery a human ear
so when David comes in with a warm meal
she's like no thanks I'm full
understandably Ellie's luck you people
are [__] but what were they supposed
to do starve Ellie should know more than
anyone that sometimes terrible things
must be done in order to survive Joel
for example has killed multiple people
to defend Ellie and David knows that if
he were to give Ellie a knife right now
and let her out she'd kill him without
hesitation just like Huang saw something
in Ellie in episode 7 so too does David
Illy is a natural leader smart and most
of all loyal this is something he's
looking for in a partner and as we'll
see shortly the partnership he's
intending makes this super creepy like
himself David believes Ellie has a
violent heart because he himself
possessed one I've always had a violent
heart but then the world ended and I was
shown the truth you might think the
truth here is a reference to him
converting to Christianity but in a
subversion of our expectations it's
actually his belief in the cordyceps
infection the pandemic taught him that
the cordyceps aren't evil but merely
doing what they need to do in order to
survive 5 meaning feed multiply protect
and secure a future by violence if
necessary for David the cordyceps
pandemic gave him the justification for
all his actions both in the past and
present check out this list of things we
know about him and see if you can guess
where I'm going with this we know that
prior to the infection he had a
quote-unquote violent heart we know he
taught school children that he's beaten
children and we know he's had an
infatuation with Ellie a 13 year old and
that this infatuation manifests in his
sexual assault was David a child abuser
even as he was a school teacher in
Pittsburgh before the pandemic in his
messed up brain the cordyceps gave him a
justification for this abuse look the
cordyceps take what they want in order
to survive by violence if necessary
because it's vital for their survival
therefore David can do what he wants
because it's vital for his it's a bit
confusing but hell the minds of
psychopaths often are and here's the
icing on the cake he says the cordyceps
do this because it loves yes love will
be the justification for him doing
terrible things don't be afraid
there's no fear in love but why is David
telling Ellie all of this well he says
she can handle it while the others need
a sham figure like God to give them
strength for him he sees Ellie as an
equal a fellow Shepherd to lead their
people but that still leaves Joel David
assures Ellie he'll let Joel go if Ellie
decides to stay and become his partner
imagine the life we could build once you
have a seat there and get comfortable
from that and for a moment we aren't
sure what Ellie is going to do that is
of course if you haven't played the game
she destroys the [__] out of his finger
and in a fun call back to never telling
him his name she finally says tell them
that Ellie is a little girl who broke
her [__] finger tell sassy
David doesn't take too kindly to the
fact he's just had his finger broken
saying how did you put it
tiny little pieces a reference to her
being chopped up and put in their next
meal meanwhile Joel trudges through the
snow towards Silver Lake breaking into a
tackle and bait shop where he finds
Ellie's bag so he must be on the right
track and poor kallus the horse is
unfortunately here as well in the game
he finds his way into the back of a
butcher shop where he too discovers
these hanging bodies meanwhile David and
James grab Ellie to turn her into a
delectable stew but she bites David's
hand a moment that doesn't happen in the
game but she definitely gives David a
reason to pause when Ellie reveals that
she's infected they pull up her sleeve
and David doesn't believe it's possible
she would have already turned and Ellie
uses this opportunity to grab the
butcher knife and ax down James before
making her Escape there's something very
meta about the new Ellie killing the
actor who played Joel in the game
Ellie's prison isn't connected to the
steakhouse so we get this big sequence
where we follow her as she sneaks her
way through the resort town and as we're
making our way through Silver Lake we
can hear just how disgruntled some of
these men are with David's leadership
it's hard to make out here but some of
the men want to put his leadership up to
a vote at least Trek will eventually
lead her to the outside of the
steakhouse where we can see the ruined
t-o-n-d from the Todd Steakhouse signage
Outdoors back in the show Ellie attempts
to escape but all the doors to the
steakhouse are locked David searches for
her and she does what any rational
person would do throw a burning piece of
wood at him I thought the game version
was a little bit more believable here as
the fire starts by an oil lamp falling
over David believes Ellie isn't infected
because no one infected would fight that
hard to stay alive so he's curious to
know how she did it and he's made the
decision not to kill her I've decided
you do need a father
so I'm going to keep you
and I'm gonna teach you super creepy the
game treats this segment like a boss
fight in which Ellie uses stealth to
navigate around the restaurant while
ambushing David with carefully placed
knife attacks eventually culminating in
an attack which quickly cuts to Joel in
his quest to find her this leads him to
that meat locker but we also find a
curious piece of paper here which
denotes the pounds of human flesh
they've accumulated each month we then
cut back to Ellie struggling to escape
David and lunging for her butcher knife
but the show takes David's motivation
here to a much darker Place implying
that he's about to rape her he says
things like he likes it when she fights
and that there's no fear and love as he
reaches for his pants am I the only one
still paying attention to this giant ass
fire behind them look I'm not exactly
sure how much love this guy was planning
to do with a fire bigger than Andrew
Tate's career right now the game doesn't
really lean into David's sexual desires
it's just crazy David trying to kill
Ellie but David's death is way more
gruesome in the show in fact I counted
22 stabs before Ellie stops butchering
his face compared to the 10 in the game
and Ellie's attack here feels as though
she's possessed it reminded me of when
Joel lost control attacking the federal
soldier in episode 1. in terms of the
show this is Ellie's first verified kill
of a human in the game she's already
killed a dude in Pittsburgh and even won
while escaping David on Horseback in the
show we know from episode 4 she shot a
man but it was Joel that finished him
off and we aren't exactly sure what
happened to Riley after she was bitten
did Ellie finish her off as she turned
in episode 4 Ellie tells Joel that
shooting the man wasn't the first time
that she shot someone so it's entirely
possible Ellie's first kill was Riley
but again we don't know if this is true
or how infected Riley was when it
happened the game actually has Joel
stepping in to stop her as she kills
David while the show has her outside
before she's reunited with him she is
insanely traumatized not wanting to be
touched until she sees that it's Joel
her words are difficult to get out as
Joel tries to calm her and for the first
time in the show he calls her baby girl
the same thing he called his own
daughter Sarah in episode one it's okay
baby girl come on baby girl come on baby
girl I gotta get you I love this shot
here because we can clearly see the
broken watch a constant reminder of
Sarah's death as he Embraces Ellie the
two walk off into the distance together
luckily off to Salt Lake City the next
step of their Journey the game ends this
segment with the burning Steakhouse on
the knife embedded in David's skull as
we cut to spring so it'll be interesting
where the show takes us in the finale
apparently Ashley Johnson will be making
an appearance as Ellie's mother and if
it follows the events of the game we are
in for one hell of an episode but let me
know what you thought about episode 8 in
the comments below every comment like an
engagement helps me rank in the
algorithm for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
[Music]
thank you